israel launches a series of deadly
retaliatory strikes on gaza
hours after rockets were fired from the
palestinian enclave
the retaliatory attacks which began on
monday night mark a significant
escalation in tensions in jerusalem
they followed a day of heavy clashes
between palestinians
and israeli police inside the al-aqsa
mosque
hundreds of people were injured when
police fired stun grenades and tear gas
at palestinian demonstrators later
israeli nationalists gathered for an
annual march through jerusalem's old
city
to celebrate israel's capture of east
jerusalem during the 1967 six-day war
many palestinians view the march as a
provocation
the catalyst for the violence is
israel's plans to evict a number of
palestinian families from east jerusalem
to make room for jewish settlers for
many the evictions are just part of a
wider trend
it's a matter of a whole policy that has
been targeting the old city targeting
and of course targeting isawe and other
places and they have surrounded
jerusalem
with enormous settlements trying to
extricate jerusalem from its palestinian
environment
the international community is now
calling for all sides
to de-escalate
well for more now let's bring in yara
hawari she's political analyst at the
palestinian think tank
al-shabaka and a freelance journalist dr
hawari before
we get into the underlying tensions here
tell us how do you explain
the current flare-up in violence
i think it's very important that we look
at the historical context of what's been
going on in jerusalem
and really in palestine this is a
context of ongoing
ethnic cleansing of palestinians and
colonization
of palestinian land and that the latest
goings-on in jerusalem is just one
manifestation of that
the attempted eviction of palestinian
families from is really part of a larger
attempt to judaise jerusalem and to push
palestinians
out of jerusalem so the protests have
really uh
been in resistance to that ethnic
cleansing and ongoing colonization
and they've been inspired by their
brothers and sisters in cheshire
who have been really remaining steadfast
amidst ethnic cleansing
okay so you're putting this in terms of
ethnic cleansing
and the palestinians responding to that
you mentioned the evictions as well in
terms of
what might be causing the current flower
but what prospects do you see
for addressing the issues driving this
conflict between israelis and
palestinians
i think when the international community
and actors are calling for
for calm and a de-escalation they're
really evading
the responsibility that the israeli
state has which is to
end the occupation and colonization of
palestinian land there is one
aggressor in this situation these are
not clashes or skirmishes these are
violent repression of palestinian
resistance to that ethnic cleansing
and colonization so that context is
incredibly
important when we're thinking about
possibilities
for the future and possibilities to end
the violence
it really lays in the hands of israel
okay so
you're seeing this very much from a
palestinian perspective in searching for
a solution
to the conflict how much of an obstacle
though
are the divisions among the palestinians
themselves and their
inability to even hold an election for
example
were you right in saying that i'm seeing
this from a palestinian perspective as a
palestinian but this isn't only a
palestinian perspective international
organizations and the u.n have long
identified israel as an occupying regime
and have condemned
ethnic cleansing and evictions so this
isn't simply a palestinian perspective
it's actually an internationally
held perspective now what's been
remarkable about these protests
i would like you to talk about the
palestinians themselves if you wouldn't
mind because
absolutely could you speak to that
these absolutely yeah the the
resistance and the protests that we've
seen over the last few days as i was
saying across historic palestine is
remarkable and really really quite
something to see
because palestinians across the
so-called green line are uniting
under this banner of which is actually
really much larger than it's about
resisting ethnic cleansing across
palestine and so
we're seeing incredible scenes from
nazareth from haifa from ramallah from
jerusalem
of palestinians uniting under this
banner
of resistance against ethnic cleansing
okay so
you don't really want to address the the
conflict between hamas and
fatah
administration because the us has often
played a role as
or tried to play a role as mediator in
all this um
the trump administration promoted arab
recognition of israel
moved the u.s embassy to jerusalem gave
a nod to israel's claim to the golan
heights
what are your expectations for the biden
administration
i think we're likely to see a
continuation of u.s
policy which really appeases the israeli
regime we might see a sort of a
friendlier face
the trump administration was certainly
very crude uh
and certainly very obvious in its
support for israel but i don't
think we'll see massive change in terms
of u.s policy
towards uh israel we know that the u.s
has long
been an ally of israel and moreover has
long been a donor of military aid
to israel i don't see any changes uh
any changes in that in in the days to
come
dr hawary thank you very much for
talking with us that was yara hawari
uh from the think tank in
the palestinian terrorists al shabaka
thank you very much
thank you